you used to work here and we you and I
toured together Andy and you what we
went on to or years ago you've always
been a big part of our family and now
you've gone on to bigger better things
but do you ever miss working here is
there were times you think oh man I miss
that car yeah it like I was doing [ __ ]
today like I love that I miss that but
it was a few times I was like I'm never
coming back here ever let me show you
something got a pizza yeah was it was a
bit we had you do oh yeah we had you
play I think we had you played a hobbit
I think once on the show I was a hobbit
yeah and I'll roll all the way home with
no radio after that yeah just quiet yes
just no radio we've all done things yeah
you were it was nice you your last
special you mentioned working here oh
yeah I've mentioned like like working
here it was like super super nice and
white and a lot of things they used to
happen was like I'll have a sweater on I
don't know I haven't wore sweater around
white people ever again but right you
know your sweater get really messed up
right here those little balls I was
taking it off and the other writers was
laughing at me and I didn't know why but
they were laughing because I was picking
cotton no for God's sake
you should have come to me and told me I
was like its swing roll ACP right now
call
[Laughter]
you